The Exorcist believer is a new take on
the 1973 classic that has major
potential for two killer sequels it
stays grounded in the original narrative
with Ellen Buren's return as Chris
mcneel it pulls from actual stories of
real life possession and keeps the
audience on their toes with some
gut-wrenching horror that even had the
director's skin crawling there's already
a high bar attached to this movie
because the 1973 film made such an
impact on pop culture in
General see I can do it too okay you
don't scam me sweetie but this blumhouse
movie is the most expensive one they're
making yet Jason Blum and his production
company signed on with universal for a
$400 million deal the money Skyler where
is the rest that entails two potential
sequels he says this is the riskiest
movie of his entire career he shares a
bit about his anxiety in his interview
with sci-fi quote just because it's so
expensive usually the bar to success on
everything we do because it's
inexpensive is incredibly low for The
Exorcist it's high like I mentioned The
Exorcist believer is most likely going
to be a Trilogy they're trying to follow
in the footsteps of the Halloween sequel
released in 2018 but the approach is
going to be a little different
cinematographer Michael Simmons teased
the potential Vibe for the upcoming film
quote it's certainly more suspenseful
and claustrophobic and true to the
original material a Halloween movie is a
movie that jumps up and stabs you an
exorcist movie creeps under your skin
and gets you and continuing to compare
and contrast the Exorcist to Halloween
the Legacy built on Michael Myers and
his obsession with lri Strode is treated
more like a soap opera with lots of Camp
callbacks and drama there's just so much
they're able to reference from the past
30 years The Exorcist isn't going to be
like that at all there will of course be
nods and references to the original but
the take on the story is going to be
completely fresh what would the Exorcist
be without the return of the iconic
Chris mcneel Ellen Burston returns after
50 years and she's more excited than
ever to revisit her legendary role what
are the experiences that happened to her
those 50 years in theory it makes a lot
of sense because she's one of the few
people who lived through this we've met
before Mother her daughter Reagan was
nearly taken from her in that 1973
classic and now this time it's not only
one person's daughter it's two who have
been possessed also in real life over
the course of these 50 years people have
come to Ellen with their own personal
stories that relate to her character's
Journey the evolution of this project
began with some of my inspiration from
Ellen and her real life story which
brings us to the topic of the immense
research that was done to bring this
story to life when director David Gordon
green was researching possessions for
this movie he found a case where up to
five people were possessed at the same
time by the same entity thinking of that
scenario and exploring all the
perspectives of each possessed person
and the people trying to help them
became the driving force of this movie's
conflict if you think about things
differently than I do how do we work
together to free these kids of this
being Lydia JWT and Olivia Markham the
possessed teenagers in question had a
lot of fun getting into character
especially when it came to the makeup I
have this big bulge on the side of my
head so sometimes in a scene I'll like
turn like that so like the light can
catch it and even when they didn't have
creepy makeup or Prosthetics to work
with they used other tactics to create
fear things that weren't so outwardly
noticeable like facial expressions voice
demeanor just very subtle creepy changes
it's more fun to see the different ways
you can show that aggression David
Gordon green would give them
instructions on exactly how possessed
they were 50% demon 80% demon and they'd
have to adjust accordingly I think
that's the fun and challenging part is
finding those differences you know the
two girls are also best of friends on
and offset what's more fun on a creepy
set like this than being possessed with
your bestie their personalities are also
actually opposite to that of their
characters in the film Catherine is the
one who's always pushing Angela to talk
to people and be more outgoing I think
the dynamic is a lot like ours but lck
because I'm more the introvert and she's
more the extrovert the climax of this
movie also known as The Ensemble scene
for David Gordon green he says filming
that scene was like running a marathon
it took all day the difference in
experience and skill sets and age and
energy it was tricky in a lot of ways
they ran it through like a play they did
a lot of rehearsals and blocked out all
the movements before rolling out all the
cameras and Equipment they needed
everything to be perfect because it was
one of the few scenes where everyone was
all together and needed to bounce off
one another if you don't have a pretty
airtight game plan you're going to find
yourself in a pinch it was an emotional
intense all day Affair if you don't have
a pretty airtight game plan you're going
to find yourself in a pinch with
hundreds of millions of dollars behind
this production an insane amount of
dedication from a legendary team and
true stories of demonic possession
pushing this narrative forward The
Exorcist believer is pushing to be more
than just an homage to a classic film
it's trying to make Horror history
what's your favorite behind the scenes
moment
he